there will be a brand new judge joining
her at the desk a man who told me he
thinks Heidi is crazy
Simon cow look who's talking is all of
this necessary I don't actually bite
that's not what we heard
so how long the fans been waiting to see
that TV's toughest judge tussled up
Hannibal Lecter style is sometimes a
little brutal and therefore we put him
in a straitjacket I'll give you whatever
you want whatever you want please don't
okay it's all in fun promoting Simon's
new gig on America's Got Talent he's
taking over for Howard Stern and
bringing along his signature attitude I
don't believe we didn't get any buzzes
never too late honestly don't waste your
time it's hard enough if you're good
it's impossible if you're awful so I
kind of think it's like a public service
sure Simon but you're not the only one
who can dish it out he needs a makeover
because he is a handsome man but did you
see these jeans on this man we should go
shopping I'll think about it
you should not think about it just say
yes are you drunk
i couldäôt wait to see these two
together at the judge's table